كل ما فكرنا فيه بشأن كافاكانتي
ورحلته كان صحيحًا، لقد كان
رجلاً يائسًا وكان يتجنب
الاعتقال، وبعد فترة وجيزة من
هروبه من السجن كان قد
احتمى في منطقة
منعزلة جدًا ومشجرة جدًا ولم
يتحرك من أجلها.  في اليومين الأولين، قال
إنه نجا من البطيخ الذي
وجده في مزرعة، وكان يشرب مياه النهر،
وكان يخفي فضلاته تحت
أوراق الشجر وأوراق الشجر حتى
لا تتمكن سلطات إنفاذ القانون من تعقبه، لقد
كان رجلاً يائسًا أيضًا.  وصف
حقيبة الظهر التي حصل عليها والتي تم
الحصول عليها في وقت مبكر من رحلته، حيث
أخذها من أحد المسكن، وهناك
حصل على ماكينة حلاقة، وأنا أعلم أن الكثير
من الناس تحدثوا عن كيف
أصبح حليقًا نظيفًا، هل ساعده شخص ما بشكل جيد بكل
بساطة؟  كانت ماكينة الحلاقة في
حقيبة الظهر، لذا أجاب على الكثير من
الأسئلة بالنسبة لنا ووصف أيضًا
قدرًا متزايدًا من إنفاذ القانون
كل يوم، وهذا ينطبق على كلا
المحيطين، وفي النهاية لهذا السبب
قرر مغادرة منطقة Longwood Gardens،
قال ذلك في العديد من المرات  وصف
ثلاث مرات أن
مسؤولي إنفاذ القانون كادوا أن يدوسوا عليه
ثلاث مرات ولكن هذا يثبت لك
مدى كثافة الغطاء النباتي وأوراق الشجر،
لقد كانت مجرد منطقة هائلة
للبحث فيها، ولا أعتقد أن الجمهور
يفهم مدى صعوبة الأمر
الحرارة الشديدة والظروف القاسية لتحديد
مكانه، لذا في اللحظات الأخيرة وأنا أنا
أنا أركز على شيء قلته والذي
قاله في المقابلة اليوم إنه
كانت هناك ثلاث مرات
كاد ضباط إنفاذ القانون أن يتدخلوا فيها
قلت عنه إنهم كانوا على بعد سبعة إلى
ثمانية ياردات، أعني أن هذا أمر
لا يصدق جدًا أن نتخيله وهو يرقد
هناك ويختبئ في
النهاية عندما تم حل هذا الأمر أخيرًا
عندما حصلت عليه، كان
كلبًا كان كلبًا اسمه يودا  لقد
كانت المساعدة في القبض على كافوكونتي أمرًا بالغ الأهمية في
الواقع لكل هذا، هل يمكنك إخبارنا المزيد
عن الكلب عن الكلب المسمى يودا
وما فعله الكلب
حتى أتمكن من إخبارك أن هذا الكلب كان
متمركزًا في ديترويت بولاية ميشيغان وهو
جزء من Vortech التكتيكية  أعتقد أن الفريق الذي
كان متمركزًا خارج ميشيغان يبلغ من
العمر ثلاث سنوات، وهو كلب مالينوي بلجيكي
وكان ضروريًا فقط فيما يتعلق
بالتتبع والبحث بالنسبة
للعديد من الأنياب الأخرى التي كانت هنا، كان لدينا
كلاب مالينو أخرى وكان لدينا كلاب شيبرد ألمانية وكان لدينا كلب
صيد للدماء  لذلك
تم استخدام كل موارد الكلاب هذه
من فرق تكتيكية مختلفة من
المنطقة وكانت مجرد مورد لا يصدق،
أعني أنه أمر لا يصدق، فماذا
ذهبت لتفعله فعليًا وأود مرة أخرى أن
أذكر الجميع أنه في الوقت الذي
تم فيه القبض عليه و و
أداة Yoda في هذا الكافوكونت لديها
بندقية أفهم أنها بحوزته
في منطقة Arm's Reach
وهذا صحيح، لذا أه على
ضباط البورتاك وفريق سيدي
شرطة ولاية بنسلفانيا يقتربون من هذا
التوقيع الحراري، تحدث المقدم بيفينز
عن نعم أحد
ضباط vortec جسديًا  لاحظت أحد
الفرسان في ذلك الوقت،
تم إعطاء أوامر شفهية لكافالكونتي بمحاولة الفرار
عن طريق الانسحاب ببطء، وكان
القرار التكتيكي الذي أفترضه Vortech
وشرطة الولاية هو نشر هذا
الناب الذي عرفنا أنه كان مسلحًا
ويستخدم نابًا شعرنا به  كان
خيارًا معقولًا قبل
الترقية إلى القوة المميتة عندما انتقل يودا
إلى كالفوكانتي وأعتقد أن
الشيء الوحيد الذي ظهر في ذلك الوقت هو
رأس السيد كافاكانتي أو تاج
رأسه وانتهى به الأمر بأخذ عضّة على
قمة رأسه وهو ما أعرفه.  كانت الصورة
تخرج مع الكثير من
الدماء وهذا هو سبب
وجود الدم لأنه أخذ قضمة
باتجاه أعلى رأسه الآن الكلاب
تعض وتمسك كلبًا لذلك لم يكن هناك أي
إمساك عندما يعض عندما تشتري
شخصًا ما  في تاج رأسك، لذلك
تم عض كافالكانتي مرة أخرى في
منطقة الطرف المنخفض التي
أمسك بها يودا ثم استسلم السيد كافوكونتي
للأوامر وتم
احتجازه من قبل
فريق تأكيد يقترب من شرطة ولاية بنسلفانيا